well number one on what influenced my
work is is brightest ring of angels
around heaven that's number one number
two is a little novel called The
Stepford Wives by whoever wrote that dr.
seuss cat in the hat is a great seminal
piece of thinking and writing I had a
phase with Truman Capote where I just
loved his very early in my writing life
where I was just in love with some of
the beautiful paragraphs and sentences
he wrote and I still think in cold blood
is a great great book Fitzgerald and I
love Gatsby and the longer one the one
that took him 10 years Tender is the
night tenor the night breaks my heart
and it's always one of those books that
I almost can't pick up again because I
don't want to put myself through how
hard you know how touching and
heartbreaking the ending of that is
robert penn warren 'he's all the king's
men is I you know I just love that book
so much and in fact I ripped off some of
the lyrical nature of some of those
paragraphs i gave to ponyboy and instead
of a guy instead of driving through the
Louisiana heat I have pony boy riding
his bike through the Las Vegas streets
and it's a there's me a couple
paragraphs in there that are direct you
know okay riding God's robert penn
warren wherever you are this is this is
my salute to you those I think are some
of the real real landmarks and there's
many many more and I'm sure for hours I
will be replaying this question in my
head that's a good one
you